[Musik]
ainring sie alle zu messen
sebastian deckt das geheimnis der
perfekten industrie zwiebelringe auf 123
würde ich sagen ganze zwiebeln kommen da
bestimmt nicht rein zwiebelringe für
dich persönlich superlecker mache ich
mir ab und zu auch zu hause
[Musik]
das sind für mich zu geringe so wissen
wir aussehen
richtig schön dick weil die größe weil
die größe oder auch mal ganz groß aber
die aus dem tiefkühlregal und wie die
das schaffen das zeichen jetzt dieses
geheimnis verbirgt sich unter der panade
mit der zwiebelringe so großzügig
umhüllt sind sebastian lege deckt auf
[Musik]
das ist gar kein syring das ist eine
zwiebel masse da sieht man kleine
stückchen ein bisschen fein anteil
[Musik]
für standardisierte zwiebelringe
brauchen wir einige zutaten ob zutat
wasser wasser und zutaten in pulverform
so kocht die industrie am liebsten alles
nahezu endlos haltbar und für die
maschinelle verarbeitung gut geeignet
statt auf echte zwiebeln setzt lege auf
getrocknetes zwiebel granulat sorgt sie
sofort voll für den nötigen halt sorgt
ein spezialmittel aus sebastian lege
trickkiste mit true zellulose steckt
sogar den tapeten kleister und auch in
vielen industriell hergestellten
zwiebelringen methyl zellulose wird aus
baumwollfasern gewonnen in lebensmitteln
wirkt es wie klebstoff einmal kurz
aufkochen und die zwiebel masse bekommt
ordentlich bindung
1 zwiebel breit würde ich sagen ich
probiere mal eben dafür typische meine
reiche mit zucker
funktioniert ja ein paar frische
zwiebeln gibt der produktentwickler
trotzdem noch dazu so will er den
typischen bis erreichen ohne echte
stücke wären die zwiebelringe am ende zu
weich
meine türe ist fertig und jetzt form bei
die zu einem wunderschönen zügel ring
formen ist ein ganz sensibles thema in
der lebensmittelindustrie form werkzeug
ist richtig teuer
die günstige variante man macht sich mit
einem stempel auf einen stärke becken
eine grundform durch den stempel
entstehen im sterbebett immer gleiche
formen
dadurch werden die zwiebelringe fast so
perfekt wie in der fabrik und sehen am
ende einer aus wie der andere
[Musik]
super dass er schon in stärke liegt weil
die stärke bin mir die restliche
flüssigkeit meines wiebel rings ab und
dann habe ich ihnen us panade ein paar
semmelbrösel und fertig ist der
knusprige mantel der zwiebelringe
gestreckt geformt frittiert das perfekte
industrieprodukt perfekt panade ist halt
immer schön günstig auch deshalb ist
frittieren eine der häufigsten
zubereitungsmethoden der
lebensmittelindustrie
es ist billig beliebt und keiner sieht
was darunter steckt war ich das schön
aus wie das geheimnis der immer gleichen
zwiebelringe liegt also darin dass keine
echten zwiebelringe drin stecken sondern
mit wasser gestreckten zwiebel masse
wenn sie echte zwiebelringe wollen
fragen sie beim nächsten mal lieber
vorher nach bei burger king zum beispiel
steckt unter der panade zwiebel 3 statt
echter zwiebel
[Musik]
und auch dieses lebensmittel sieht viel
natürlicher aus als es eigentlich ist
die paprikastreifen in unseren oliven
sind längst ein nachbau der
lebensmittelindustrie auf wasserbasis
jetzt kommt das alginat weil der
paprikastreifen so schön stabil bleiben
damit wir ihnen gleichmäßig und auf
geschwindigkeit ausfüllen können
sebastian legis paprikastreifen sollen
am ende etwa zur hälfte aus alginat und
wasser bestehen
jetzt kommt die paprika rein und damit
farbe und geschmack stimmen bis
paprikapulver die masse besteht gerade
einmal zur hälfte aus frischer paprika
erst das pulver sorgt für geschmack und
intensiven geruch richter schon
intensiver paprika vorteil der
künstlichen paprika masse sie lässt sich
maschinell viel leichter verarbeiten als
frische paprika
echtes gemüse ist für die industrie viel
zu ungleichmäßig geformt
[Musik]
eine schöne paprika matte streifen
hier müssen wir nur doppelt legen und
dann vorsichtig in die olive
hineinschieben fährt ist einfach genial
dieser trick mit dem paprikastreifen
deshalb nutzen ihn auch alle bei einem
test einkauf im supermarkt gibt es keine
einzige olive die mit echter paprika
gefüllt ist
wahnsinn oder
das hätten sie doch niemals gedacht dass
so wenig paprika in dieser füllung
steckt paprikastreifen oder zwiebelringe
die hersteller machen natürliches
künstlich nach immer dann wenn sie
produkte massenhaft zu geringen kosten
herstellen wollen
und auch äußerlich haben die hersteller
einen trick auf lager der den gewinn
ordentlich nach oben treibt den
mikrowellen trick die
lebensmittelindustrie hat in den letzten
jahren ein ganzes sortiment an
mikrowellen gerichten entwickelt das
versprechen genuss in wenigen minuten
es gibt currywurst kürbissuppe oder
chili con carne mikrowellen gerichte
hand aufs herz wenn es mal schnell gehen
muss zack zwei minuten rein und der
hunger gestillt
aber haben sie auf die schnelle mal auf
den preis geachtet hätten weil über
machen sollen
es ist einer der besten tricks die
produkte entwicklern bisher eingefallen
sind
er ist so gut dass verbraucher immer
noch darauf hereinfallen
auch 50 jahre nach einführung der
mikrowellen gerichte in düsseldorf macht
sebastian läge das experiment er hat
zweimal chili con carne mitgebracht
beides angebliche neuentwicklungen für
den supermarkt ich hab neues format
produkte entwickelt sich gut aus oder
guck mal hier sehr sehr appetitlich habe
diese war schon mal gekauft ja ehrlich
gesagt schon okay was meinen sie was
wäre ein fairer preis für die jeweiligen
produkte einfach mal wir haben mit zwei
tafeln genau zwei tafeln zwei produkte
und beim preisausschreiben ein fairer
preis zweimal chili con carne einmal in
der klassischen dose und einmal in der
plastikschale für die mikrowelle
es stimmt dass sich in der dose
ja aber jetzt auch weniger drin deswegen
muss es eigentlich ganz sicher sein aber
schon 23 sebastian lege hat 400 gramm
chili in die mikrowellen schale gepackt
die düsseldorfer sind bereit zwischen
drei und sieben euro dafür zu bezahlen
in der dose ist gut doppelt so viel
chili enthalten
das kennen solche produkte sie sind
relativ relativ hochpreisig ich denke
dass ich ein bisschen darüber liege mit
dem preis und diagnosen gerichte kennt
man fliegen denke ich so in der richtung
die befragten haben im supermarkt
offenbar gelernt mikrowellen gerichte
sind etwas besonderes und darum teuer
dose dagegen ist immer günstig diese
fertiggerichte
das ist ja noch irgendwie weiß ich nicht
irgendwas anderes und habe zeit zu
irgendwo gesetzlich mehr für das ist
halt der ersten großen unbedingt immer
das ist wahrscheinlich frisch lackiert
das ergebnis im schnitt 1 eur 95 würden
unsere tester für eine dose chili zahlen
für das mikrowellen gericht dagegen mehr
als 4 euro
aber von wegen frischer besser gesünder
in der mikrowellen schale steckt oft
genau das gleiche wie in der dose weil
viele verbraucher das aber nicht wissen
freut sich die industrie über stattliche
extraprofite fantastisch gleicher inhalt
neue verpackung und drei euro mehr in
der tasche
so macht arbeiten spaß und so zieht sich
der mikrowellen trick quer durchs
sortiment der einfallsreichtum der
produktentwickler es schier grenzenlos
karibus zum beispiel kostet für die
mikrowelle umgerechnet 18 euro pro kilo
im vergleich zu 6 euro wenn man sie in
der pfanne brät oder auch tassen
tüchlein 16 euro 20 verlangt dr oetker
pro kilo und damit ein vielfaches von
dem was normale backmischungen kosten
und so geht es immer weiter
absoluter liebling popcorn aus der
mikrowelle da schon mal auf den preis
geachtet 10 euro das kilo für mich
persönlich ganz schön happig weil ganz
normaler pop corn mais der ezb kosten
drei euro das kilo und wo setze
unterschied
solche das mal verraten es gibt keinen
popcorn poppt wenn man es heiß macht
ganz egal ob im topf oder in der
mikrowelle
es ist allein die verpackung die
mikrowellen popcorn so teuer macht
knapp 10 euro gegen drei euro pro kilo
ein massiver preisaufschlag verbraucher
sollten sich nicht blenden lassen
mikrowellen gerichte sind selten besser
als herkömmliche produkte
sicher aber teurer der wesentliche
unterschied liegt in der verpackung
und die rechtfertigt in den seltensten
fällen preisaufschläge von mehreren
hundert prozent
[Musik]
nachgebaut und schön verpackt wo
vermutet du noch mehr optischen tricks
sagt es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips